freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
heute für thomas tommy und es geht
direkt los mit bananen pantex zuckerfrei
wird ein paar kleine changes zu gehen
ich freue mich dann aber ich hatte auch
schon durch viele kommentare gesagt
haben kann sie nicht mal laktosefreien
sicher dass das nach heute haben wir ein
bisschen was davon erreicht die
challenges weil jeder also wir sind hier
im büro so und jetzt ein bisschen andere
eigene sachen der eines latour sind oder
waren
die haben das digital und aus seinen
verschiedenen selbst experimente sind ja
auch changes beziehungsweise mitbringen
sie erwarten so zum beispiel wenig
zucker vollkorn er hat genau damit
arbeiten wie heuchelt gelegen los so
freunde hier sind wir also es gibt wie
gesagt bandhomepage außerdem arbeiten
die mit laktosefreier milch und es wird
sehr lecker ich probiere mich trotzdem
ihr wisst ich liebe fluffy pancakes
mobilität trotzdem wirklich hoch zu
bekommen und schönen flachen zu machen
nämlich das sind die besten pics wir
statten bekannt indem wir 360 gramm
weizen vollkornmehl abbiegen darum geht
vier teelöffel backpulver und wir können
eine ganze packung wenn man das ganz so
wie zucker machen kann man jetzt hier
vier esslöffel zucker hinzufügen wir
machen jetzt ganze gleicht aber mit
agaven ticks ab und dementsprechend man
mir das im flüssigen teil also dann
gehören wir uns jetzt auf unseren
flüssigen anteil von teig sondern nehmen
wir uns jetzt 500 milliliter nicht schön
hier unsere schüsse drei eier zeigen die
hier hinein dann gehen wir jetzt noch
zwei teelöffel vanille exakt und jetzt
drei esslöffel ergaben gesagt hätten wir
die eier und verkehr das ganze und
daneben geht unter die trockenen zutaten
so das ist jetzt alles schön für meine
frau mir unsere bananen ich habe extra
welche genommen schon ein bisschen
brauchen einfach mehr süße die geben wir
jetzt hier hinein und zerstampfen sie
ein bisschen ihr wisst ja vielleicht ich
bin eigentlich gar nicht für bananen
fehlen aber
nachmittags wird auf jeden fall das ganz
anderes tier ganz übernahme mich dafür
und die schlampig jetzt klar alles schön
sie auch stammten so wir wollen sie gar
nicht superfeinen haben als es ein
bisschen noch so ein paar stücke drin
hat es eigentlich perfekt und natürlich
auch schon die bananen zum rest des
teigs hinzu und heben die jetzt runter
so das war's schon
dann setzen wir auch schon die fahne auf
bzw am besten sogar direkt zwei fahren
weil es soll viel und brauchen wir ein
bisschen zum ausbacken weiter rechts
weitergeben ein klein bisschen öl in die
pfanne sowie per text oder ausparken
kümmere ich mich schon mal um die
toppings ich habe da so eine edel
bitterschokolade gut ohne milch und
zucker und sonst fast beispiellose und
noch mal fürs auge und auch ein paar
bananen schreiben thomas trenkler auch
die bei dem das nächste scratching auch
die bayern ist ein klein bisschen aber
wirklich nicht das tier bei dem eine
gute textur dazu und man schreiben wir
uns noch die letzte bananen und spielen
ein bisschen entscheiden damit toppen
wir sehen uns gleich beim essen
[Musik]
also darf man merkt halt ein bisschen
länger ein kleines sieg gewacht bleibt
ja in szene also wir haben
bananen can take mit vollkorn nehmen
kein einziger zug angaben blick sagt ja
da sehen richtig sei dass die dortigen
amerikanischen viel geld genau das
empfiehlt also danke dass du nimmst dir
pancake nimmst den ersten bissen man
geht die kamera ausgelastet auch die
dann wenn wir uns erst wieder ein
komplett aufgegessen hat und jetzt kommt
oft erzählte wusstest du dass du einen
krassen film der marktzugänge zwischen
stecken damit die uns aufmachen die
kleiner film the flag die machen das
epub dinge dazwischen dass diese dinge
sind im weg stehen und schütten motoröl
ja ja ja das problem habe ich profitiert
habe ich vollkommen okay nicht viel
sagen
wir sehen uns vielleicht nicht
aufgegessen ist ja fast alles
auseinander genommen möchte zu viert
dieses weißen vollkornmehl man kann es
nicht aufessen aber ich bin sehr
gespannt wie ist ihr geschmeckt ich
finds gut also ich bin unabhängig davon
was zu mir passt auch gut aber wir
müssen das nur warum halten das für eine
charity smid mit diesen karten
das ist halt keine das ist halt nicht
geschummelt das jetzt nicht so hälfte
das hälfte lassen das ist normalerweise
volk wollen die verstaatlichung
staatsoper 16.000 konzern versuche waren
negativ wirkliche ziel sei es immer so
nett aha also optisch gesehen auf jeden
fall haben wir 19 900 sich und schlagen
das haben sich hören dass mitte ich war
auch ein bisschen überrascht das nicht
gut ja was bedeute dass ein guter anfang
zu mittag geht es mit einer sache die
wir sortieren nicht haben aber in einer
ähnlichen form wir sehen uns zum
mittagessen wir machen ein malfanti das
sind so kleine spiele schlüsse bisschen
ähnlich zeigen oder patti nur dass keine
kartoffeln reinkommen und so und wir
fangen an indem wir den spinat waschen
so
wie spinat marie und ist plötzlich über
das wenig sonst entsteht nämlich ins
zwiebel herstell und wölfle
jetzt habe ich einen großen topf
aufgesetzt und gebe einen kleinen stich
vorteilen hinein und dann gehen wir auch
schon die zwiebel in butter
und wenn sie so jetzt will die zwiebel
angedünstet sind geben wir auch den
spinat dazu und spinat lassen wir 2012
nächstes mal wir parmesan
beziehungsweise planer pagano 70
der spieler führt in der zwischenzeit
reduziert müssen wir vielleicht auch
ausbrennen hinaus 70 zusätzlich zu
unserem parmesan dreier und zwei eigelb
in eine schüssel geben so dazu kommt
dann der parmesan und 250 gramm rekord
so dass ganze rühren wir jetzt klar
und jetzt sollte unser spiel ab fertig
sein
den schlag mehr und jetzt komplett
reduziert und schützen ihn abgegeben
jetzt hier wieder fasziniert wie wenig
das letzten endes ist und jetzt bringen
wir nicht aus wie auch schon beim
istanbuler partie muss hier wirklich so
viel flüssigkeit aus wie es geht was ihr
allerdings schon machen kann es hier
einen kleinen topf aufstehen und
mittlerer hitze wo ich jetzt noch mal zu
100 prozent geben und zwar dass unsere
sei bald mutter die schmelzende schön
die frauen werden sondern wir den spinat
man hier auch sonst ihr seht es wirklich
lächerlich wenig im vergleich zu
beginnen und den haken wir schön fallen
sondern können wir jetzt auch schon
unseren spinat nehmen und den hiermit in
die schüssel geben dann will ich jetzt
mal 230 gramm von unserem vollkommen ab
ich weiß nicht wie sich das auswirkt
dass das jetzt mit vollkorn ist hofft
passt weil sie müssen jetzt ein paar mal
hier runter und dann gehen wir
stückweise bisschen mehl dazu schlau
wäre vielleicht eine größere chance
genommen zu haben aber das mache ich ja
häufiger so das geht mir ja ordentlich
mail auch die arbeitsfläche jetzt das
hilfreich mit so ein bisschen nach den
händen zu arbeiten weil dann klebt das
ganze nicht so geführt wenn jetzt mal
stehen teig und schnappen wir uns hier
so ein vierter und formen daraus nicht
an belegt armee sparen dabei aber je
mehr man nutzt desto fester werden dann
am ende auch die klöße hier wollte ich
jetzt mal alles schön aus und fertig
sein
da sind die ziele wollen ich habe
vergessen zu werden ich hab kein muss
katrin kein pfeffer und salz
das heißt die welt das wasser jetzt
geistes kennzeichen und dann am ende
halt alles nochmal drüber geben aber es
ist auf jeden fall nicht optimal wenn es
schneit jetzt hier immer so paar stücke
ab und dann freue mich am ende noch so
die spitzen aus malfanti das heißt
schlecht gemachte wortwörtlich
dementsprechend muss alles nicht perfekt
aussehen
wir machen das ganz einfach so ungefähr
die zu so bonk
alles klar wir geben jetzt die malfanti
hinein und zwar die großen als erstes
auffällt
unterschied macht und dann die kleinen
hinterher wenn die hochschulen sind
unsere mutter ist auch schön gebräunt
und derselbe also infiziert und ihr
körper gleichen nicht drin nach muss
sich in rot und klick und auszuweiten
kann solange sie einst sind nämlich
schon eine gute prise parmesan darüber
wichtig wie schnell sich ein bisschen an
[Musik]
so weil wir ganz hinter dem fa
mein fazit das teilweise brutal ganz
genau magst du gerne wohl gerade bist
noch war kabel das wird gefehlt hat
börse nehmen einmal den ergebnissen
stehen aber alles vollkommen sind ganz
genau mit vollkommen es riecht es nicht
gleich ja okay da sehen wir es schon
gleichauf gewesen auf ihr so gut dass er
wann leitet das ja das habe ich schon
leichter ist also ein leichtes wir haben
jetzt 16 30 haben sich zeit für das nach
dem frühstück haben auch steht
gefrühstückt aber das war durch
überfällig nicht gut dass man mal was
bis zu 15
dann bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt hast du
das gemacht was würdest du dir geben
lediglich er fest und das ok ok ich hab'
ich würde mir eine siebeneinhalb geben
wahrscheinlich geben erklärt ich finde
ich hier jetzt ein bisschen salzig
gesenkt oder bisschen einfach sein ich
sagte ich habe vergessen
ich habe ich vergessen zu witzen und ich
habe ich habe vier hände voll salz ins
wasser getan und dann habe ich noch das
kart unter den parmesan gemischt denn
ordentlich drübergefahren die quasi
nicht gewürz das hat nicht sehr sehr
zufrieden mit mach ich muss es unbedingt
noch mal einen fehler machen quasi war
richtig geil und es war wirklich riesig
ich glaube das ist vollkommen richtig so
gut funktioniert hier auf ja das ist
will ich dass ich habe ja vollkommen
macht glaube ich hätte keinen
unterschied geschmeckt wenn es trotz
technisch also mit acht wenn die selbst
befriedigt wird sagen wir sehen uns zum
abendessen und was mit kras und wir
kommen zumal am ersten leute wie ihr
seht habe ich jede menge zutaten vor mir
der ich bin ich hab ich auch jede menge
arbeit vor mir
thomas hat
von ihrem messer das gewünscht also
griechische tapas quasi wir bleiben bei
dem ganzen vegetarisch und als
allererstes bereite ich hasse sachen
auszusprechen ohne zu wissen wie man sie
richtig ausspricht makes a no salata
also salat aus auberginen wir fahren mit
dem berlin die stechen wir einmal ein
aber der heizen wir den backofen auf 200
grad ober unterhitze wird schon eine
weile über schienen noch die spiele weg
jetzt haben wir sie halt dann geben wir
auch unsere oper in alufolie in den
backofen und lassen wir doch erst mal so
eine halbe stunde drin dann machen wir
weiter mit unseren zucchini das sind
weiße zu klinik ich beim türken geholt
habe im schnitt sind sie und was mir
einmal niemand zwei verschiedene sachen
mit den zucchini und zwar bereiten hier
ein paar auf dem grill und ein paar
machen wir zu zucchini puffern die haben
auch einen griechischen tapas namen aber
ich weiß es nicht nur um der aisch
schneiden vorne und hinten achteinhalb
jahren wie die ganz das ganze schnell in
der fall etwa so 3 mm dicke scheinen so
das blatt
ein bisschen olivenöl marinieren das
passiert mir hier was von ihrem sigrid
griechischen lieben irgendwann sondern
jetzt ohne marinieren oder umwerfen
zweite tapas auch vorbereitet nur so
können wir auch vorne ab an den zucchini
und seine schälen wer sie das sind
übrigens 600 gramm sowie rast mit
unserer zucchini ziemlich groß wie ihr
sehen könnt
das ist immer so auf aktiver
16 gericht auf einen monat eigentlich so
der royals 2 knoblauchzehen die werken
wird ein der eine krise wirklich auch
klar dass geht mir jetzt zu den zucchini
dann kommen dazu 200 gramm haferflocken
70 gramm käse gerieben ich habe zwar
mühsam und zwei eier sondern das ganze
vermengen lehrt einer masse war es
wieder verwerten zu würzen
das stellte jetzt auch schon bereit
machen wir natürlich hier gleich aus ich
habe hier eine salatgurke geschieht wir
machen wir nicht mit tzatziki weiter
die salatgurke halbiere ich so und das
weiche innere kratzen wird mit einem
löffel aus hinten vorne ab sodann reinen
wir jetzt die salatgurke ebenfalls groß
da gehen wir 250 gramm quark ganz
normalen nicht mager oder so und 250
gramm griechischen joghurt also zehn
prozent fett stufe zusammen hinein das
verwöhnen wir und ich habe auch einen
guten stücken das wasser herausgepresst
jetzt gebe ich die gurke dazu dann
presst sich noch zwei knoblauchzehen
reihen das jetzt bewusst nicht super
viel pfeffer
das ganze herunter es hat wirklich
fertig und wollen wir mal hier
überwiegen raus komplett durchgerostet
so dann ziehen wir jetzt die haut ab von
der maschine zu schneiden einfach mal
der langener über weg sondern die
richtige version würde sie aus und gibt
das innere einfach hier in mixed freude
thomas ist jetzt auf dem weg hierher das
wird ein bisschen zu stressig ich mal
einfach alles fertig ihr seht die
angerichteten sachen jetzt und dann
kommen wir zum ersten freude
das war eine schwere geburt wo sind mega
happy mich dass hier alles sehe und ihr
habt ihr gerade auch gesät aber ich muss
aber die kamera ausmachen weil es war
wirklich tausend sachen auf einmal alles
ist rechts hätte ich gleichzeitig fertig
geworden dementsprechend hoffe ich dass
auch alles nochmal und lecker ist die
besucher erstmalig aussprechen dann
selbst ist ja sehr gut gemacht er hat
keine ahnung ob ich da muss so viel
sagen so viel ich habe wirklich von
allen die mengenangaben für knoblauch
halbiert oder getötet aber er ist
potente stehen verbraucht wenig gehört
hat man nicht an ist der 1
oder doch doch besser schon komplett
durcheinander
zusätzlich ist das wichtigste oh ja auch
gut so wir kommen zur bewertung wir
haben nicht alles weggehauen aber das
war natürlich viel oder wenig schlafen
könnten gut vorstellen dass so viel
verkehrt vielmehr von maniche gehen
müssen auf alles ein tabu sie krähen der
shit also die stadt ist auch super
lecker of pop ist gar nichts lunia
supergeil eine zucchini waren richtig
lecker auch brot wasser perfekt dazu der
hier war auch megageil der fed da so die
einzigen zwei sachen also die man aus
supergeilen nadine politik aber es waren
keine klassischen
und so endet ja die wir nochmals i
tüpfelchen gewesen bisschen punktabzug
mit gm ist unser sorgenkind oder also
ich finde ich glaube da hätten keine art
gehört ich weiß auch im unterricht hat
das war ein bisschen zu lässig eine
gesamtnote sie okay noch einmal die
aktie jetzt besser aber an sich aber
super g hatte sich die spaß gemacht und
dazu muss man ja sagen durch deine
freunde stehen die übelste expertise in
der griechischen küche auch neben büro
fragen also mit meiner ersten
berührungspunkte deshalb bin ich auf
jeden fall sehr zufrieden mit den sieben
von zehn es geht ein koch intensiver tag
zu ende was gutes